confidence ah good afternoon everyone
and welcome to the app clinic my name is
reto Meier i'm ian ni-lewis and today
we're going to be looking at stopwatch
and timer apps now just so you know
today's kind of a weird day we've got
some people out of the office sick we've
got some you know important meetings
going on so we have a new engineer
engineer Joe Hey Joe is well known for
his graphs with linear algebra and his
oddly ethnic last name so thanks for
joining us Joe you can tell that they're
important meetings because we're here
exactly
now the truth is we did ask Alex to be
our producer because we thought with the
beard and all absolutely but here's what
happened there really the odd story so
alex is a really really you know
flexible guy he does a lot of thing you
ask him to do a Google i/o presentations
sure you ask him to you know build a
brewery with his bare hands sure no
problem industrial solvents I meant to
be inhaled hock welding yeah absolutely
he can do all these things asked him to
engineer deer-in-headlights I wondered
why he was running down the street that
is indeed yes so alex is a man with a
comfort zone and we have you down the
edge of it taking us a couple of years
but we have found the edge of his
comfort zone good job yeah yeah yes
all right let's get on with it so we're
gonna take a look at some stopwatch and
time wraps today like always our goal
here is not to necessarily find the best
stopwatch and timer app but to try and
look at a few and see if we can help you
guys out there developing your own
Android apps to be able to take your
good apps and turn them into really
great apps so what are we gonna have a
look at today be blank screen wow that's
going well mm-hmm
I'm not sure where he was hmm interested
it's very interesting
that's a key note not helping me out
there right indeed yeah we started doing
all of our titles in keynote because
it's so cool but now that his very
little sort of hilarious I'm not really
sure what
you should just not you clicking things
you shouldn't it clicked in here there
we go there we go
I feel like this is gonna go poorly
should have stuck with PowerPoint so
these are the patients we're gonna try
and take a look at today we'll see how
we go with our overlays but so we look
at yogurt I'm will looking to look at
timer alarm stopwatch and clock impetus
interval timer hybrid stopwatch and
timer and the ultimate stopwatch and
timer so we can definitely see
consistency in naming there so that's
that's something so before we get into
it I'm going to try another transition
and see what happens yeah so what we can
see here straight away is I'm just gonna
screw around with other things well the
fact is the camera is not pointed at us
correctly oh wow so what you can see
straight away when we look at today's
patients is this these are the feature
graphics so we can see straight away
that only three of our patients had
feature graphics hybrid stopwatch
ultimate stopwatch and and one of them
doesn't have the name on the feature
graphic which isn't in and of itself not
a bad thing but what I really wanted to
highlight here is when I'm browsing
through the market all of the names of
eglee the same and so I'm going to try
and pick something which looks pretty
appealing before I get going and and
straight away here one which really
stood out to me was the hybrid stopwatch
which just looks awesome it's got a
great feature graphic it's got a great
icon and the others really didn't stand
out so much and so I would sort of
instantly assume that was the best one
just based on on the way it looks so
that's I guess let's get started I guess
and and have a look at the first of the
apps which is actually going to be yoga
timer
and so this is the this is the page that
you see on Google Play when you go this
so as you can see no feature graphic so
that's missing let's talk about that for
a second because I don't think we've
really talked about odd on the app
clinic
we've talked a lot about how you can
make apps interesting you might want to
go ahead and just remove this overlay
all right because no no don't do that
don't ask Joe to do things Hey look that
we can do ah okay
rock on and I see you've put yourself in
frame and now I'm a little you know
producer Alex did love you friends yeah
okay
hey I was way over here I know you were
I'm not saying that right you know I was
exactly um I had set it up I'd spent
time getting this right all right here's
the point we've talked a lot about on
how to make great app on this show but
we haven't necessarily covered the
merchandising aspect quite as much and
you know there's a reason for that we're
not merchandising people but there are
some things that we can share with you
about app merchandising that will really
help you because they're things that
aren't necessarily obvious about how you
upload your app into the Google Play
Store and the most important thing the
thing that a lot of people get wrong is
failing to include the giant feature
graphic there's one graphic I can't
remember if it's just called X large or
maybe it's web or something but you'll
know it because the dimensions are giant
it's 700 by 500 thank you gave me a 1024
by 8 anyway it's it's the one that's
really large and a lot of people leave
that out and then you don't really
notice it because the phone only uses
that in one place and the only place
that image gets used is if your app is
featured then that image will be used it
seems important but the web page for
your app you will use that as the main
graphic and you can see that the web
page still fits together fine without a
feature graphic it just doesn't look
quite as good but the important thing is
we can't feature your app unless that
graphic exists so keep that in mind when
you're creating a graphic
a couple other things to keep in mind
are that the graphic does get scaled
down for different devices so on a very
small phone for instance that graphic
that's you know thousand pixels wide may
end up only being an inch across so you
do need to make sure that your graphic
is not only large but legible at
different sizes let's go ahead and move
on
absolutely alright so gonna have a look
at you a Gotama so that's the first
piece of feedback from them is that
there is no feature graphic but let's
have a quick look we're going to do this
the same sort of format that we did last
week we're gonna have a quick look
through each of the apps and then we're
going to show you guys what we think it
takes to make a great timer stopwatch
app and then have a look at some of
these apps in comparison to each other
keeping those prescriptions in mind
right so let's switch to the to the
phone can if we can awesome work see
Joe's doing a much better job with this
anyway yeah actually that's true now I I
spent my week drinking in Maui and doing
blow so Latos gonna review these apps
and I'm gonna sit back and have a black
bead porter form Deschutes Brewery nice
that goes on so yoga timer is an app
designed specifically around being able
to create tongues for your yoga workouts
so you can see straight away we've got a
holo themed layout which is nice please
add workouts so yeah we've got a blank
screen but it's telling us what we need
to do right now to make something happen
we've got an icon which has a little
plus symbol which is kind of the Android
symbol for click here to make something
happen so let's let's create a quick
workout
appiy oka this is what we do before and
after each show to listen up
same pre-show pretty interesting now one
thing that that applies to this out but
it isn't necessarily a timer app is that
it's more broadly applicable is a lot of
times you see this thing where you this
sort of behavior where you have to enter
something to create something to get
started with an app and one one of my
pet peeves is this sort of behavior
where I have to I have to create
something in and it involves typing yes
and I know that there are people that
are more nimble-fingered than I am
apparently some CEOs compose their
entire annual report on phones
Wow but for me what especially when I'm
just downloaded your app and I'm trying
to decide whether it returned it or not
mm-hmm I don't want to have to sit there
typing maybe pre fill those fields with
something that sort of makes sense which
gives you an idea what the app is for
like a sample and example workouts
something like that I think yeah if
you're if you're if you want to go the
extra mile make that something where it
will autofill if you don't type but as
soon as you start typing it'll go away I
mean really no I like that so let's
navigate in here so again now there's a
second step so we've got a P ok now we
need to add a timer for that particular
exercise
tricky from an angle so they've got an
interesting mechanism here for doing
this so you can drag things along
instead of having to type which is nice
I'm not gonna do a three hour workout
all right that's why they don't just use
the spinners yeah it's it's kind of an
odd choice we're actually hoping to be
able to speak to some of the developers
from these up so next week so I wimps
the question we may post it in so yeah
keep that in mind guys have you watching
so now we have an activity and we have a
timer for it we can have multiple
activities and multiple timers and if we
click here things start to happen and
now we have the you know the standard
sort of countdown time where we can
pause got some kind of nice little
animations in there for pausing and
resuming we have it here in the
notifications and in fact a rich
notification that's nice and that's
basically all there is to it so it's a
fairly simple app for specific purpose
and I know that Thea developer of this
this is pretty new I know he is putting
this together hopefully in time so that
we will be able to review it for the
show so uh but you know a
straightforward layout you've got
settings behind the settings in the
overflow in the action bar does what it
needs to the only sort of criticism is
is exactly as you suggested it's you
can't get started straightaway you have
to do text entry text entry time entry
before you can get started yeah and
we've seen this a lot in focus groups
that we've done with consumers is that
they will very frequently only give an
app 30 seconds or so before they decide
to get rid of it and you definitely need
to grab them yeah in the first few
seconds we get a little jaded about
things like tutorials and stuff like
that but I think that if the consumer is
comparing a couple different apps
getting them into something interesting
immediately is paramount yeah the only
other thing that I'd suggest is honestly
I found the ad really confusing because
it occupies the same mental space as the
list items I what do you think I was
gonna say it maybe shows the other mark
was kind of the most standard place for
I'm sort of the mental cognition here
it's like action bar and then add and
then content and it struck me as a
little bit odd as well so yeah I'd
considered might consider shifting that
I think the ad is more visible that way
I think you're gonna get more clicks
that way but I think a lot of them are
going to be accidental and you know be
careful about that as well I love the
app I love the ad platforms have
guidelines against putting your ads
anywhere where it may accidentally being
clicked and I'm gonna be you know in
fairness here it's a little bit tricky
because if you put it towards the bottom
you could be trying to hit navigation
and accidentally hit the the end if you
put it at the top you've got the same
problem in the action bar so there's not
really an obvious answer but this I
think just from a usability perspective
seems like it's going to be too too easy
to hit the bottom by mistake absolutely
it's great up though yeah yeah it's nice
and clean we'll get into some of those
specifics about it later but that's
that's the functionality nice and simple
yeah they framed it nicely which I love
that exactly it's a standard action bar
but with definitely a color scheme
that's on the consistent tonight yeah so
yeah I think the only other thing that I
would say is I think that this should
probably be centered or something like
that how what does it do when you go
into portrait or in the landscape selfie
question well I think it's a ListView
right it is always here okay let's
enjoyed that because we can add several
time this year oh I see so that's why
yeah gotcha okay cool
all right let's move on alright so some
look the next up we're gonna have a look
at is timer alarm stopwatch and clock
and as you can see again no feature
graphic here either so again so this is
this is an app where when I first looked
at it on Google Play I wasn't expecting
much no it's kind of it's it's a very
busy icon which you know if I look at it
now I can figure out what it is but it
you know it doesn't really strike me and
there's no feature graphic so you know
it was a little bit apprehensive to
begin with the good news is when I
actually opened up the air
it's actually pretty nice so we've got
the holo theming right off the bat it
does exactly what we asked before before
and then you press the button and it
starts the obviously you've got the
stopwatch functionality there I didn't
have to do anything I'll open click it
mm-hm and right away now as a user I go
oh okay well this is quite nice already
do yeah yeah it's like you got the
Lambada fonts you've got this
ridiculously fast moving thousands
indicator yes I'm pretty happy I hit rap
and I get my lap times fades in nicely
it's got more then that is nice yeah I
like the faders I'm pretty nice right I
mean I mean there's a few things I'm
really excited to see what Roman has to
say about this next week because to me
it seems like they've done everything
right and yet something is slightly off
and I think what that means is it needs
a designer to just go and kind of lay it
out and put the finishing touches on it
I just think this is a recent redesign
from these guys I think released just
yesterday or in fact early this morning
specifically so we could check out the
new stuff and so I think it's a first
pass on a new design yeah looking pretty
good but yeah this it feels like there
may be little things that can be done so
we're gonna pause the pause the start
the stopwatch and we can go to a
countdown timer and you say so I clicked
that the same as I did the stopwatch and
it tells me that you need to add a
counter in order to guarantee no does
that were the toast I would kind of
prefer that if I do this rather than
tell me that it just does the equivalent
of loading up that button right well it
seems like I can see why you have it
here as well that's reasonable well you
know but it really reminds me of that
that do you remember the part in the
Hitchhiker's Guide to the galaxy when
Arthur and forwarder and the the
spaceship and somebody pushes a button
and he's like what that do I says how it
a little light that you can't popped up
that said please do not press this
button again
that's what I feel like when you do that
it's like oh you interacted with my UI
but not the way I expected yeah don't be
doing that I think that I think it's a
little more courteous to just assume
what your users want it exactly that
makes sense you've got the ad counter
button here and fair enough have that
too but let's do both so okay again here
the button style here is a little bit
odd again it's this you know it's a very
attractive looking at and then you've
got kind of an orphaned button sitting
by itself sort of floating in the middle
so I'd consider maybe moving that around
but I only back to the design guys to
say they've got an opinion we've got the
strata standard spinners here which you
can actually see it's a pretty intuitive
way of changing the times so maybe
that's a tip for the yoga guys there is
you know this actually isn't a bad way
of doing it no it's pretty alright it's
a I think that the way the yoga guys did
it makes sense but it's just not as
intuitive exactly so you can see here
it's added a timer again I would
probably be tempted to automatically so
now to set the timer I need to click
here which then assigns it to here and
then I click it again to get started now
keep on adding a timer I think it
probably makes sense to talk about it
what is select that select oh yeah will
you I don't know well mate unless
personally if there's a timer going
maybe you don't want to do that sure so
if there's any timer in action that's a
different story
what happens if we add multiple counters
into the look
so the we've got a new kind of down here
the old one continues I assumed that if
we uh yeah so once you click a new timer
it resets I don't know if it wants a
warning there or not probably not I
don't want to do a confirmation because
you are losing work exactly so you don't
want to be like oh but I was just
clicking it to edit it and that's not
how you edit then that's one week pretty
annoying we can see here as well we have
a we have a countdown time which is nice
and in fact I think that's even
progressing I didn't actually notice
this but that is cool
but that's really slick you can see
probably just here the little blue
circle representing the amount of total
time remaining as well as the active
countdown I really like this I think
this is it shows two things for me one
that there is an ongoing foreground
service running so that my timer isn't
going to stop just because I'm browsing
and using up on my memory and I don't
need to go back into the app to see how
much time I've got absolutely fantastic
yeah so again here we click to pause or
click again or we can reset we can
delete these they disappear all of that
works really nice we have alarm
functionality which works the way you
would expect it to and a nice little tip
here as well they've got a world clock
which is nice totally you know not
something I was expecting to have as
part of a stopwatch and timer app but
you know why not right you're doing
stuff with numbers overall the theming I
think looks great we've got it's a full
screen button here for the world clock
that's quite nice
don't know what that does Oh attendeth
same time Oh actually switch modes
prefer the the Wyatt's it doesn't have
been designed for yeah exactly so yeah
and I note here that I can't actually
change it from here I need see its
dropped down into the fish theme yeah
it's Jo that'll yeah into the overflow
menu okay that's interesting
that is interesting that's probably a
reasonable way of doing things have it
in the action bar if there's room I
would say though that this theme looks a
little less polished than the dark theme
I think a lot of people prefer the light
theme I think you probably want to tweak
your colors particularly down here and
the lap timings a little bit it looks
like they just haven't gotten around to
that yeah exactly and knowing that this
is a relatively recent release and say
that's fair enough
okay so this one do a little bit of
everything it looks pretty nice it's not
bad it's not bad at all let's have a
look we're gonna move on to impetus
interval timer next so this one does
have a feature graphic but it's a
terrible feature graphic it's not good
it has a huge amount of text all over
the place
I should point out that our green screen
is what is making the that's true like
the middle part there see yeah nice
so now though it would be a much better
feature graphic no yeah so in fact that
part is us at least but but in any case
you can see here that it's a feature
graphic full of text and one of the big
places that this is going to get used is
when it's shrunk down a full feature and
none of that's going to be visible and
even still this is more what you would
expect from the screenshots rather than
from a feature yeah in fact you should
never put screenshots in a feature
graphic we will never feature something
that just has a screenshot in the
feature graphic and in fact in this goes
for a lot of things like I've seen games
with screenshots in the feature graphic
and that's no good
which you really have to ask yourself is
when you go into a software store let's
say you're going into Best Buy and
you're gonna buy some kind of software I
don't care if it's a game or if it's a
business suite or whatever what do you
see on the front of the box well it's
not it's not a screenshot right it's
usually some sort of beautiful art
sometimes it's conceptual yeah bitch
makes you go this is professional
related designer to do this now where do
you find the screenshots screenshots you
find when you're playing the game yeah
well that's not the answer I was looking
for but the answer I wanted was on the
back of the box the box right but that's
okay because I know you only buy
software digitally these days all right
all right what is this exactly they've
completely gotten rid of them in the
rest of the world here we're still
playing football with a ball that's not
round so the point is that you you do
want to have screenshots but the plates
that they go is in the little screen com
where everybody expects them to be and
you should have something beautiful and
conceptual in your feature graphic
exactly and you've got a nice icon as
well it's exactly the idea what you're
talking about it's it's you know it's
conceptual its artistic it looks nice
get an idea of what it is you know what
actually I have to mention that since
you you brought up icons the one thing
the one thing about yoga timer that
really needs to change is its icon yeah
I can get it now yeah in general the
guidelines for Android icons are that it
should be a the outline of the icon it
should not be a square or a rounded
rectangle and yeah keys or just get out
line I think it's the the guidance
exactly all right so let's say let's
have a look at impetus
I can click it so right away I start
this up and this one's a little
confusing it's not obvious to me
straight away what's going on there's a
lot of text on screen well apparently
you're finished well indeed so let's
move on that's not fair so that's kind
of the biggest challenge here is that
you need to figure out what is going on
so if you click on edit you get an idea
that oh okay so this seems to be some
sort of exercise timer rather than just
a straight-up timer
so that's themed and that's fine but
again nothing was obvious about that in
in the name or in the nature graphic
nothing was telling me hey this is an
exercise timer so go back to timer I
click on stuff that's not doing anything
hmm
go no time set then a toast again
you know do not press this button again
okay so now I've got some presets so I
can say let's do let's do a pyramid
preset okay so now we're gonna and now
we're gonna work out so we don't exactly
know what it is that we're doing I don't
know what pyramids are but that's
probably I thought I knew what pyramids
are but I'm struggling to make it make
sense with this so the other for a way
that it's displaying things with the the
progress time here is nice you know
showing us the total time and the time
for each you know repetition or in this
case rest is nice we've got lots of
notifications
see all right so we can say that we've
got an impetus session in progress it
isn't rich it doesn't show the ongoing
details but you know at least at least
you get sea bass going which is a good
stop we can pull oh I know what it's
doing you're right it's it's you do a
little rest you do a little more than
rest you do more than rest yeah okay so
it's this I've heard of this is a way to
to build up your endurance training for
running I guess so I've never done it
with time I've always done it with reps
mmm but that's because I have no
endurance nor need for any endurance
really no just raw strength raw strength
that's all about um so you can see we've
got these alarms and these they just
kind of fall off the edge of the screen
here you can see if that's my yeah isn't
great yeah and this whole dialogue is a
little odd like how do I dismiss it is
it right at all hooked into the no in
fact check that out I'm I'm just
pressing the volume keys okay yeah if we
bring this that's certainly not in a no
that's just very strange yeah so I'm I'm
at a loss to explain what they've done
everything customs being done there and
it's not something that's right let's
see so we can so this is how we create
new presets so you know I was clicking
here we can use the existing presets
abandon the current session so you can't
browse when you set while you're doing
one which I guess makes sense because
you're in the middle of exercise yeah
things and then you can do all of your
new C presets save preset again seems
like if you created a new one you
already should have been able to save it
well that's true actually seeing a Save
button in general is sort of a bad smell
to me in UI design now the it used to be
important because you're saving to you
know floppy disks or something right
before for a long time the the only
reason to have a save function is that
so you can give whatever it is you're
saving a name
when you don't need a name or if you can
give it a default name you should just
save automatically there's no reason not
to all right so then I guess I have to
save yeah so the workflow around this is
is kind of complicated and not entirely
obvious I'm gonna leave the I'm gonna
leave the guys from from Android design
in action to sort of go into some of the
di don't know if they're gonna talk
about this one it's got I think they
yeah I think I think the that they like
a challenge I don't know I okay but all
I'm saying is I don't want to be
anywhere near Roman on Monday
let's see now this is where Romans being
very clever didn't on Tuesday so the the
other guys Adam Nick rich there you are
they'll be doing the design show with
with Romans help in creating some marks
but the range will be elsewhere hello
there boldly drinking
I'm joking a little bit but the truth is
that this app breaks almost all of our
UI guidelines there's custom buttons
that don't quite work there's these
buttons down here and you can't quite
see my needs lift that up it's difficult
to tell on the screen but these buttons
have a little border around them which a
they don't need be looks shabby we
called out the X motif style of Android
design I'm trying to get a room and get
away from that yeah so I mean this seems
like it's a fairly useful app I like the
that it's the news theme is not just a
timer it's it's able to you know build a
workflow around timing but I think the
workflow around being able to get things
set up and going is a little bit
contrived is a little bit difficult to
understand and the overall look and feel
I think if we compare it to some of the
other apps we've looked at today you
could do a little bit of work
absolutely now I just want to break in
for a second and remind everyone that's
watching that producer Alex is
monitoring the live stream diligently
right it's what diligent looks like so
if you have anything you'd like to ask
or some comments you'd like to make
please go ahead and let us know because
we do this live for two reasons one so
that we have an excuse for all the
mistakes that were sure to make
and to because we'd like to have your
input
absolutely so let's move on to the next
step which is going to be the hybrid
stopwatch in Thomas and I want to buy
that right now really caught my eye
right yeah I click through like a dozen
or so timer stopwatch apps when
selecting them for today's show and I go
to this and I was like oh I can't wait
to play with this that looks cool I look
beautiful and it's got this great great
icon this massive feature graphic which
is just totally in-your-face and if you
compare this to the screenshots we took
of the other listings it's just not
today
yeah it's like clearly someone's put in
some effort here and to be honest it
looks like it's basically F it done once
like they're put in the effort to create
something which is an awesome looking
stopwatch and then they've just used
that as their theme throughout and I
have a hunch that when we open up the
app it's gonna look pretty similar yeah
which is which is exactly what you want
you know give people the idea of what
they're gonna get with you know without
having to get to you know screenshot
like right okay tell us have a look so
hybrid stopwatch we open it up and boom
looks like exactly what we would expect
I believe that's what we call in a
business skeuomorph ake possibly yeah
yeah uh-huh
so as you can see it works as you would
expect we hit stop and it starts when we
see the the timer along the top going
off we see the Apple dial going around
which is nice stop stop sit nice the
button depresses and under present now
this it doesn't use the Android design
guidelines at all but I don't think it's
necessarily a problem now I know that
the other guy didn't look at this is
wrong I'm sure they've got some ideas to
make it a little more hollow like while
still maintaining the same sort of
overall look and feel but just generally
speaking this is great I'm not bothered
that there's you know yeah and that's
one thing that we should say to you I
think that a lot of times on the show
we're saying oh well you know they don't
have an action bar or they've messed
this up and the truth is we don't want
every app to look the same we want all
Android apps to look the way that's
gonna be most affected right so when we
say you're not following the design
guidelines what we usually mean is
it looks as if you might have been
trying to follow the diet design
guidelines and you got it wrong these
guys want a completely different way you
really did
it's intuitive it's very beautiful great
everything you have no problem with us
like everything works the way it would
and I really like it their attention to
detail here so when I press stop if I
hit reset it's actually going oh yeah
right that's nice because that's what a
mechanical device would do absolutely
along you hit lap and you know leaves a
little marker behind for each of our lap
timings which is nice
let's see now it does use the old style
menu button which way the same what is
it do stuff so lift it up here so you
see what the menu even that you have a
menu button it would be kind of nice now
to have an action bar to to hold it in
that that more modern style right you
know you've got such a nice-looking app
it's kind of a shame but if we go
through each of the lap times it's all
again same sort of they can't sit same
theme style consistent which is nice I
will say that as we've said before the
gradient effect can look really nice but
when it's just applied over and over
again it yeah sort of looks like well I
guess somebody got a hold of Photoshop
this week yeah it's a little it's a
little bit of the lens flare effect it
really looked cool when no one else
could do it but now everyone can do it
it doesn't look quite so cool yep send
lapse unfortunately this should just be
a share intent rather than email and SDO
absolutely can it however I want if I
want to tell my friends on Twitter how
fast I can run then I should be able to
do so now now we can switch to timers
kind of the other key here so they've
kind of got a custom standard which is
too bad because this is how Android used
to work and it wasn't very easy to use
and now we've gone to the the spinner
that you can fling which is a much
better design and it's it's too bad to
see this sort of thing still popping up
and this is this is a real risk that you
have if you go oh I almost like what the
platform has done there but I want
create something which looks a little
bit nicer so I'm going to modify it
slightly within the platform changes
under you and you get stuck with a
slightly nicer version of a crack the
old way of doing things rather than sort
of straightaway getting the advantage of
the shiny new way so just something to
keep them can't but you know I I first
noticed this in Windows 95 when I was
working with Novell and they had a whole
set of apps where they rewritten parts
of the windowing system and so I don't
know if you remember Windows 95 came out
and they had the three buttons on the
right and they had the the title moved
over the left side and Novell still had
all these old windows that looked like
Windows 3.1 and it was terrible it is
unfortunate but yeah you can see how you
know you could you could move some of
the activity that's going on here into
an action bar on the action okay whether
it's time or a stopwatch you have Mike
potentially a you know tabs or something
to be able to talk between the two I
don't want to step on the on the guys
from Android design in action right I
just said I did want to point one thing
out about that which is you know we've
called this the button of shame and it's
it's a little bit you know obviously you
shouldn't be ashamed of having a menu
the main reason to switch to the new
technique though is because action bars
work in one very specific predictable
way whereas this button is actually now
being implemented in many different ways
by different manufacturers all right so
you can see the timer actually works
nicely it goes in a reverse direction to
the stopwatch which is intuitive makes
sense we can see the overall time being
displayed as well as each minute we can
see we do have the timer set up here as
well does display in the notifications
you got as cool as that other one that
was the best he's updating but only
every right minute she wants to know if
it rotates doesn't rotate
no nope sadly it does not sorry YouTube
was that a particular comment or just
YouTube as in that's an entire team okay
all right
who was it a 5 BR k father book 5 it
does not rotate okay so that's I think
that something else Arjun I so let's say
I'm gonna do a really quick stop at the
ultimate stopwatch and timer by team
member or Richard Hinton so we is it a
hitman I don't know I focus I Hindman
and then I sort of laugh hey I snicker a
bit yeah yeah that's kind of wide all
right rich let's see your app we've only
known him for like three years god
forbid we know he's name
so he's sure a reto okay I am oh oh you
don't know what you've just uncorked
you've got the teeth to be an iron oh oh
quit okay let's go let's my stopwatch
and time a vibe DQ up so this is truly
skeuomorphic so this looks like a
picture of a stopwatch mm-hmm any people
press it a little stopwatch thing god
that is that is cute it's pretty nice
right I have to say though I liked the
last one better because when it's
actually a picture it's a little less
obvious what's active and what's not
yeah yeah this is true this is true yeah
everything kind of works the way you
want you hit save time and it does lap
times he's using a toast to tell us that
which is luan why are you using a toast
rich come on man each time say
and we can start and stop do all this
sort of stuff which is nice you can
display the lap times he's got an action
bar going you can switch to timer mode
which actually changes the color which
is kind of interesting and yeah again
works the way you would doesn't use
their notifications at all hmm yeah are
you nice to see a rich notification
certification already then yeah
absolutely in the last five minute let's
cover the the last 30 minutes of our
show okay so we're gonna try I wonder
what was going on with the transitions
at the beginning just enough to try and
screw me over and keep me close to the
rest of it so this is this is the things
that we think really are required to
make a great stopwatch or timer app so
it's don't contradict the design guide
which is a little bit different to what
we have said in the past which is be
consistent with it and here we're
thinking well we've looked at these and
there's a bunch of different ways of
showing the time so don't feel like you
have to stick to a sort of standard
ListView action bar sort of paradigm go
outside the box just don't contradict
anything which we said we should be
doing you know make sure that it's
intuitive include the functionality for
timer and stopwatch because I don't want
to separate apps if I have one app which
does one really well and one out which
does oppose almost as well I'm the
missile of a single app notifications
foreground services we talked about and
keeping it simple
you know really easy to use as you step
through so we're gonna look at now I
have to I have to say Rito you know I
didn't say anything before because when
you put this together I was still in
Vegas coming down from a really bad acid
trip but the the one thing that I
noticed on this list that is missing is
widgets widgets yeah that's true that's
true
we did I did not even think to check if
they had widgets so let's have a look
let's see analog clock DeYoung tog be on
pod got a lot of things installed from
previous weeks but I'm not seeing any
because it sort of seems like a natural
well the problem with I think one of the
problems that you have I guess you could
use it to start other things because you
just don't want to have the widget which
is getting updated as a time okay
because that you know you really want to
be updating your widgets every twenty
minutes something like that I see but as
a quick way to start it and then have it
with the newer notifications would
actually be pretty neat yeah so yeah
that's a good point so this is you know
one of the reasons you didn't put
widgets on is because updating widgets
are expensive you don't want to have
that just going on all the time exactly
so having the ability to just have a set
timer on my home screen I'll be able to
kick off the stopwatch as a timer and
then it you know automatically starts
displaying things here you know ultimate
stopwatch does tell us when it's
complete just not and once I'm gone
rising yeah I think the what I loved was
that the one that actually counted down
although the one thing that I would have
done differently but tell me if this is
possible because I'm not too familiar
with the notification code um would it
be possible to actually animate that a
little more because if you've got a long
time err it's just gonna crawl forward
right and I've noticed that what
basically all of the operating systems
we work with have moved towards is this
paradigm where if your progress bar
isn't making much progress at least
it'll be animating you know like I think
Mac does a barber pole effect and
Windows kind of has a shimmer and I
don't know what UNIX tear Linux does
because I am NOT geeky enough but yeah I
think you have enough time in shell
exactly and you'll notice I don't have a
beard which means I may or may not be
able to program stream if you can code
there's no reason to shave here's here's
a thing though if you're um if your
progress bar is not going fast having
some animation at least lets the user
know that something is happening and I
was wondering well could we put in like
you know a little shimmer or something
and I think you probably could I mean as
they've got the the outer edge
I'm having something in the middle just
happening to show that it's that it's
ongoing I think would be an interesting
effect I am I don't know that there is I
don't know what overhead is associated
with updating it okay you know you think
about it can't be that bad because we do
that in the download manager that's true
we have a little you know I think it's
actually just an animated image so you
know what I would do is an animated
image and then just overlay that arc on
top of it that could what yeah
absolutely
okay cool that looks like a really quick
look through if I only got a couple of
minutes literally so we were going to
spend a little bit more time contrasting
and comparing but again you know in
terms of the design guide I think really
the the hybrid stopwatch is is kind of
one of the most interesting deviations
from the design guide which still look
good
I do have been given a preview as to
what the other guys will be looking at
on Tuesday during Android design in
action I don't know that they have an
interesting take on this app so that's
definitely something to tune in for and
the other one which i think is sort of
close to being there but not quite is
this which is a you know I think this is
a really nice effect looks really
consistent nice coloring nice theming
just I think needs a little bit of
tweaking to get it really spot-on so
these kind of the two alternatives one
more now wait a second yoga tiger
there is your katana that's true so yeah
I would say yoga timer nailed it except
for the icon except for the icon yeah
that that's the thing about yoga timer
it's a great app they've they've done a
really good job of theming it they just
aren't presenting it as well as they
should be ahead of time so yeah
other things multifunctional we talked
about so again I think this is this is
where the time control really does win
hands down it does everything that you'd
want to do consistent with time all that
went out so that's kind of that's kind
of nice rich notifications we saw a
couple of us was its iconic remember was
it I think yeah this one had it
no thoughts a bit I'll spleen lot maybe
it was just something count down yeah
there we go here we go yeah countdown
but no stop what would sure finally make
sense kind of that I'd like to have it
on stopwatch yeah so this is this is
really nice and there was another app as
well which did which allowed me to which
had rich notifications which one it was
the impetus perhaps no no it certainly
wasn't that well in any case hmm yeah I
think it was yoga timer I think was yeah
probably was yogurt sauna that's right
it was your it look at you it says
you're talking about here your timer
it's it's a it's a good app I just don't
do yoga that's my problem that's the
perfect yeah that's that's great you
having a notification is there for
information and it's a call to action
exactly and if this combines that
perfectly so they steal a trick from
from time control here and actually
included time countdown within the
notification itself you've pretty much
hit the perfect notification absolute
life is over that's yes I'm very true
uh-huh
a granting foreground service or
anything like this any time in order to
have a foreground service that is a
service which isn't gonna get killed by
the system at runtime when there is
memory pressure means that you have to
have a notification displayed so any of
these apps which don't have a
notification displayed and this is true
for most of them in stopwatch mode means
that they could theoretically get killed
by the system so that's something I
wouldn't really want to have happen and
talking to keep in mind
and keep it simple I guess that's the
the real trick the ones that I enjoyed
the most and this is why I guess I keep
forgetting about yoga timers because I
have to do so much work where I can use
you know that's true yeah you had to
there was a lot before you can just jump
in no you know they where if you
contrast that with I think was impetus
for instance just had some presets that
were there already they have a very very
complex system but they had five or six
different things that you could just
choose from to get started
time control was just all that hybrid
stopwatch was just right there right
press the button and boom you stop and
you understand exactly how it works that
that's kind of the the ultimate and even
having liked on control which has quite
a lot of functionality but it's all
pretty easy to find
yeah and then you know Rich's ultimate
stopwatch I would say is is a close
second behind hybrid stopwatch but for
me the addition of this sort of
photorealism added elements that didn't
seem germane to the application I was a
little confused by it I wasn't sure what
two types and what not to maybe that's
just me but I think it took
skeuomorphism one steps bar five now so
summer so these are the year these are
each of the prescriptions we've just
gone through and we've talked about each
of those apps and so here they are
summarized for your pleasure we won't go
through these in much detail but can
keep track of how many of the of the
green dots exist and it's really it's a
timer alarm stopwatch and clock which
does the best here kind of does
everything we asked for it could do a
little bit more with the rich
notifications in terms of the stopwatch
doesn't use them but that's kind of
nitpicking at this point and and
everybody should learn from yoga timer
about richness yoga timer is the go-to
there that really demonstrated the right
way to do this if I could just if I
could just combine yoga timer and time
control that would be perfect it's
pretty good yeah
I said look rich you need to got some
work to do rich rich so that's that's
pretty much all we've got we've totally
out of time did you put green dots by
the way on the things that we're good
because I'm that stupid so the dots that
appear transparent that's meant good
it's exactly what they meant red mint
bad transparent good exactly those of
you at home I'm going to use chroma keys
and green screens here overlays yes
you're also discriminating against
millions of colorblind people
that's true but next week it'll be old
green backgrounds with with a small red
text good luck with that so let's have a
reminder of what's coming up so Android
design in action is on on Tuesday it was
their first episode last week they had a
huge audience so that's fantastic
hopefully you guys will tune in again on
Tuesday that's 10:30 New York time and
what's that 3:30 in London and they're
gonna be taking a look at at these two
apps which is impetus and hybrid
stopwatch so I think those are the two
that they're definitely gonna check out
on Tuesday we've we've also asked the
developers are all the developers that
we talked about today I've got in touch
with us over Google+ and I think it's
something we talked about a little bit I
didn't run this past you ahead of time
so hopefully you're free next Thursday
but I thought it might be fun to spend
half an hour after we've ripped these
apps apart and the app design guys have
given them ideas what they should be
doing instead to get some feedback from
them and once they've had a chance to
digest what we tell them absolutely
that's a wonderful idea I'm excited to
be a part of it awesome so we will see
the glass from each of these developers
at our next Thursday at 11:30 that's
Pacific time you can get all of the
schedules and stuff at we're gonna run
that live to why not because who knows
what these developers are they might say
something that's true well they might
say something naughty this is the fun
thing is that none of them are native
English language speakers we've got
Austria Sweden and Spain I think oh
there's my ice so it should be fun
first thing you learn in English is
swear words that's any foreign language
I'm gonna have to have a big red button
just in case sounds good
all right friendly friendly till we are
completely out of time next week wanted
look at photography apps excellent thing
which misses with a photo so things like
your instagrams like your paper cameras
anything like that if you've written an
app if you want us to have a look at
your favorite version of that and you
know what the developers know what to
you could be doing differently or the
right way to import those sorts of apps
right you know what don't just nominate
those hipster apps okay if I have to
look at one more 70's style photo my
eyes are gonna bleed let's talk about
some really cool apps that you can do
photography with and actually shut up
hipster move
I throw it on the ground alright you
know these glasses on prescription no of
course or not and as fixie actually has
gears they're just hidden in the hub so
what we're gonna do though is is take a
look at photography apps are really
super excited about it let's hopefully
we get some actual photographers on here
I know Dan Pham is quite a photographer
easy we're gonna look at how the how
these apps can make photography easier
and more fun that should be good so I
think that's all that we have for today
we have about three minutes before Dan
Dan and I think you are filling in today
I believe yes I am I'm filling in for
the game's review which is completely at
odds with my you know new haircut and my
stylish hoodie yeah it's kind of
grayscale yeah it's a well it's a it's a
it's a boss but see there's the brand is
called boss it's by a man named Hugo
Boss Wow yeah we can't we have a boss
Hugo that's true we do yeah nice alright
so we'll be joining our Dan he's head
wear and Hugo Boss clad in Lee Lewis in
just a few minutes for
the Friday game review will be back
again next week at 1 p.m. looking at
photography apps so until then thank you
for joining us in der see you next week
bye